Katie aegyo is performing an experiment
to answer the question what happens to
your heart when you is scared I'm using
the heart rate monitors to actually
monitor each per minute we're going to
take some buzz feeders and use them as
guinea pigs to see if they can maintain
a steady heart rate in a high-stress
twisted version of hide-and-seek we'll
be taking them through this this is real
experience where you're locked up in an
abandoned warehouse watching the
gruesome treatment of the people who
were taken before you you have three
lives to be reunited with your friends
and escape successfully from the killer
like The Truman Show like watching
people like or write the truman show you
just like torturing people aka I like
watching people suffer in extreme
situations okay
there might be a stop guys to ten beats
a minute fluctuation but if it was above
25 beats per minute increase that would
actually be an abnormal response
first and foremost Jimmy's the only girl
victim on the crew so I'm really hoping
she represents the ladies so she loves
horror movies rarely gets scared and
laughs in the face of clowns that sounds
like my kind of girl man all right next
Emeka boldly and sometimes blindly goes
into dangerous situations and it also
says that he likes to be the leader in
scary situations are you gonna be on the
front lines
crying Clark
let's do it I am all about the underdog
type of responsive and has hyper
emotional responses fears blood and
violence so the whole experience guys
last but not least bodyguard from
hemstead mob dress today is the most
relaxed person here you can meet almost
impossible to rattle thinks the greatest
comedy is the Exorcist that's my dude
that's why doesn't my dude yeah I'm also
very curious to see how a day's tallness
works against him or works to his
advantage we'll see a damn fancy but our
victims ready so here's the rules we put
the BPM monitor on a PC though and they
must remain as calm as possible during
the course the first one to hit over the
average BPM about 20 to 25 beats per
minute family's heart rate right now is
it a 6 listen to this some good jazz to
help keep me mellow this seems to be
like 99 my heart rate is remaining
steady I'm not worried about anything
but am I scared I'm never scared so the
whole subway I couldn't stop thinking
about the damn haunted house I know my
heart's at 102 beats per minute so I
definitely don't think I'm gonna do well
alright guys I'm all strapped up now
as soon as you go in you get a free feel
of like what to do and what not to do
who to trust who not to trust in they
got suited and booted with Ghostbusters
jumpsuits then they got handcuffed
blindfolded and we'll put in a
single-file line with hands on top of
the other and followed down into the
cages and separated at that point and
then a torture killing spree for like
the first 20 minutes it may just let you
sit there as a witness like you're just
a witness to this crime for all you know
you're up next on the killing spree the
objective is to break free from your
cages before
find the other victims
while making sure you do not get caught
dad then you have to escape the lair
before the killers find you
[Music]
I'm not proud of myself at all strictly
on my writer I can only do stuff with
dog so there's no [ __ ] dogs and this
is real once things start getting crazy
I learned some things about myself I
could get for myself that was a very
cool
love each and every one of you but just
sucked definitely select at the core is
heart rate they actually were able to
maintain somewhat of a low heart rate
the winner was a day he started off an
average of 85 BPM I mean he was sweaty
but he was not like clearly freaking out
next time I go to a haunted house I'm
definitely taking a day with him next in
line came in really confident it's
really about composure but towards the
end encounter but I feel like it was
focused on something other than the game
that maybe kept him so calm so I don't
know maybe telling me that there was a
love connection
hey man almost to the loser yummies she
was the lowest like throughout the whole
entire thing except for when she hit 112
I learned that being chased by someone
[ __ ] terrified Hey okay so we're into
The Biggest Loser
man I know you guys not surprised by
this one it's Clark
[Music]
this dude did about like 45 over oh my
god Clark's green
that thing needs to be a sound effect
using Ford you know contestants all from
very different interests but then taking
them and putting them all in the same
room in the same situation and kind of
seeing what actually makes their heart
function it was like really cool I was
very shocked by some of the results yes
sure I felt like I held my composure
pretty well one thing that was really
gnarly about it don't you like you're a
little kid you're hiding in the closet
it felt like that but you could die and
you got to be quiet or else you're gonna
die and so when those are your two
options shut the [ __ ] up or die
you choose to shut up
[Music]